what's up guys my name is jonah welcome
back to optimization october
yes it's still happening in fact i've
been so slow with just getting
everything up and running for
optimization october that i think it's
going to bleed well into november but
we're still going to get through
everything that i have planned so don't
worry october's just a number that
doesn't make any sense my goal for this
month is to try and optimize hazel as
much as possible in terms of both
workflow and performance so before we
get to like the performance
optimizations and trying to make the
game engine run like a lot faster
because as we know there are some
serious flaws there it makes more sense
to start off with like the workflow
optimizations i guess because once we
kind of
fix those areas we'll have a better idea
of what code needs to be optimized no
point optimizing code if you're then
just gonna
rip it out and rewrite it anyway so for
those of you who haven't been following
along too much i've basically started
making a game in hazel it's called like
i don't know project orange for now
actually i released a youtube short
about it recently my very first youtube
short youtube shorts
youtube short but it's a single
video anyway i'll have it linked up
there if you want to check it out it's
like 30 seconds long go and watch it but
basically what i've been doing is live
streaming myself working on a game in
hazel pretty much all the work that goes
into that game is entirely live streamed
and we're making this game to try and
point out and like highlight some of the
performance issues in hazel as well as
some of like the workflow issues and one
thing that we found so far one of the
systems that i had to
extend in hazel was the whole mesh
system basically because one of the
features of the game is that a cube like
flies down from the sky and then it
fractures into all of these like
different pieces and that wasn't really
easily possible to do in hazel with the
way that the mesh kind of workflow
currently worked and so
i had to i had to like change it i mean
it was still possible but it was like
really really difficult let's take a
look at what the existing kind of
workflow was like so basically i've just
got a blank scene here if we have a mesh
such as this fractured cube mesh which
is this is what was shown in that kind
of youtube shorts that's what we see we
basically have like this pre-fractured
cube which is split into all of these
different pieces now the way this was
made is pretty simple you can just
create a cube in blender or just don't
delete the default one and then fracture
it using the included add-on this
creates like all of these different
pieces so if we export this cube as an
fbx and then try and drag it into here
we are graded with this kind of like
import dialogue so what this is is very
similar to like in unreal engine or in
unity if you drag an fbx file into like
the content browser you kind of have all
of these import settings in hazel it
works a little bit differently all you
have to do is
basically export the mesh into
some place inside your assets directory
so if we look at this physical like
assets directory you can see we just
have an fbx file and i've just exported
it from blender right into this
directory so it automatically appears
here and then i can drag it into the
scene but because i'm dragging an fbx
file into the scene this is something
that is called a mesh source file now it
used to be called mesh asset but then i
realized that was a terrible idea
because it's a mesh asset asset
and then we also have just a regular
mesh
asset
so mesh asset asset and mesh asset
nightmare right so now it's a mesh
source asset and a mesh asset the two
different things so what this mesh
source is is it's like the source
geometry for the mesh so this is like an
fbx file a gltf file glp file you know
that kind of thing now from there to use
it in hazel you have to create like a
hazel mesh out of it now a hazel mesh is
it doesn't like take all of the data
from the mesh source and copy it over or
nothing like that all it is is basically
some metadata for the actual mesh which
dictates how you use it so for example
you can select like a subset of sub
meshes
uh and control various other like import
settings that you would see in like you
know a regular like unity or unreal
engine import dialogue that is all it is
for the editor side of thing so while
you're working on your game it still
refers to this source asset that way you
can easily like replace it with another
fbx file if you want to or if you tweak
some settings in blender and then export
it again it will all carry across but
then the plan is this doesn't exist yet
but the plan is that when you package
your game and you build it and you
actually like use hazel's runtime that
hazel mesh file will actually take all
of the fbx data that it needs based on
what you've used and then that's gonna
it's got it's gonna basically convert it
into like a runtime format that will be
much more optimized for actual like
hazel's runtime compared to like an fbx
file which is really only good for
editing and you know authoring your
scenes i guess and your content so the
current import dialog looked like this
all it does is it lets you kind of
create this hmesh file somewhere now i
haven't actually given this scene a name
so this is called untitled scene but i
can put it anywhere i want it's a dot h
mesh file um and then i can just hit
like create and you can see that it pops
up over here and then if i take a look
at um
assets and meshes which were created if
i just refresh this you can see that
it's i also have a cube file that i used
to make this um ground plane then uh
just going to fix the shadow settings a
bit because they look awful um so so
what i have down here is this single
fractured cube now if i open this
externally which basically just means
like in whatever the default windows
program is it'll open in vs code and you
can see
uh what this file is this is the entire
like hazelmesh file uh it has this asset
handle which has since been removed
because it's completely redundant
but it's got a link to a mesh asset
which is a mesh source all of this the
stuff that i'm showing you right now is
the old workflow that's why it's like
it's a little kind of messy and there's
some things obviously here that have
been removed and all that but this is
like the old kind of workflow right so
you just have a link to that fbx file
this is that fbx file if i open up the
um
asset manager and if we were to like
copy and paste this id in here you can
see that this id is in fact a mesh asset
which is a mesh source and then here is
the file path right so that is what it's
linking to
and uh over here you have the ability to
specify a subset of what you want to use
so again um and you can double-click
this to edit more specific stuff but uh
you can see that the what it's actually
created when i've dragged this in and
now by the way i can now that i've got
this kind of mesh file i don't have to
re-import it although i can if i go back
to like the mesh source i can actually
drag this in again and create another
version of it which is just like a
different hazel mesh file but it's still
referencing that same underlying fbx
that's totally fine because you could of
course want variants of that same mesh
however if i take this mesh and i just
drag it in well it's just going to drag
it into my scene now i've got two
this is pretty uh well this is pretty
much what you would expect i guess um
but anyway with this specific cube here
though what it's done is it's just
created a single entity out of it and we
see that we have
the mesh over here it's got a mesh
component this is the actual like
fractured cube mesh that we're referring
to
that's what it's done now internally
when it's imported that fbx file which
as we saw over here hopefully that's
visible enough but it's got all of these
different sub meshes or all of these
different like meshes i guess in the
hierarchy it's actually just flattened
that hierarchy calculated all the
transforms done all of that stuff and
then essentially kind of optimized it
for rendering because like we don't need
to worry about traversing like the node
hierarchy all of that stuff for
rendering if we can just flatten
everything we can literally just iterate
over like a vector of an array and then
just render all of these pieces so
they're still rendered as separate sub
meshes as far as the render is concerned
so that gives us the ability to have
different materials for them of course
and all that important stuff but if i if
i was to kind of
um basically uh let's see if i um
visualize like all the different draw
calls the render is going through you
can see that as i scrub through the draw
calls
which i'm doing right where the facecam
is
it's rendering these pieces all as
separate pieces so they're still
separate sub meshes it's just that like
from the gameplay side of things i guess
it's just a single entity and a single
mesh why is that an issue well it's an
issue because if we wanted this to
somehow be dynamic not just a static
mesh so in this case i've got a
fractured cube but i could have the
entire sponsor model for example that
you can imagine you'd probably want that
to be a static mesh in the sense that
like you know it might be different it
might be made up of different sub meshes
different materials different transforms
all of that stuff there might be several
meshes there of course but it's still
just like level geometry that you want
to keep
as just
static geometry you just want it to be
rendered and i guess you might want like
physics colliders on it but you don't
need it to behave as like each piece to
behave as like a separate entity in your
game
with this though the idea is this cube
like kind of falls out of the sky and
then it breaks apart into pieces so for
that to work properly with the physics
system we kind of need to have
each piece be its own entity
and each piece to be like its own rigid
body and it needs to exist within like
the actual hazel scene
as separate pieces
so
how do we
how do we achieve this and the answer is
you basically can't with the current
system right the only thing you can do
as a workaround is if i go back to this
i can just say that like well you know
let's just use one piece of this and
then if i reload this you can see it's
now got one piece um i can also specify
like as i mentioned a subset of these
submesh indices to have several pieces
and then i could basically make
there's 20 of these
20 pieces so i could make 20 copies of
this fractured cube mesh drag them all
into separate entities and basically
replicate this whole hierarchy myself
that's awful what we want to do
basically and then the solution that i
kind of came up with was to have two
different types of meshes and this is
kind of similar to how other engines
work of course but it's i think it's a
little bit slightly different we can
basically have two types of meshes
dynamic and static now something like
unreal engine has like i guess static
meshes and then it has like skeletal
meshes it's kind of similar to that i
guess
basically my plan was to just take this
mesh asset and when we create it when we
create like an instance of it kind of we
can specify whether or not we want it to
be a static mesh and a static mesh would
behave exactly like i've just shown you
right we can basically just treat the
whole mesh as a single entity and it's
intended to be used for things like
level geometry
or
whenever we kind of want to still have
maybe separate submeshes here in the
actual file but we don't care about
retaining them as separate entities and
saving their transforms and all of that
stuff because we're not going to be
manipulating this during the run time
it's just something that exists like
maybe internally and we we can happily
flatten that hierarchy and just kind of
you know add a physics collider to it
sure so that you can kind of like walk
on that level surface and collide with
the walls and stuff but it's not going
to be treated as like this dynamic
entity or if you uncheck the um
[Music]
during the import dialog if you uncheck
static then what it would do is actually
replicate that entire entity hierarchy
well rather the mesh hierarchy so this
hierarchy that we have here if we go
through like all of these different
pieces then you can see that like they
have different transforms obviously we
haven't like you know we haven't baked
these transforms in to the to the actual
vertex buffer into the vertex positions
the actual like nodes here in this node
hierarchy they have
a transform
and the idea would be to actually create
a series of entities here that would not
only render a single submesh
but also they would effectively be like
a single node even if we had like empty
nodes here without geometry for whatever
reason right because we might want that
for manipulation like during runtime and
all that stuff it would create a single
entity with that node transform and with
a single submesh that we would render
and the hierarchy would be properly
replicated here so that we could then
like essentially
treat that mesh inside hazel inside our
game
as if it was just this kind of hierarchy
and structure within blender and
obviously that would work for our cube
shattering
because we would just have every piece
be its own rigid body in the physics
system it'd be like a convex rigid body
and then you know we can just
drop it out of the sky
and it's done like it would just work
because they're all separated and that
is basically the overview of this like
entire task i went a little bit deeper
into this just so that you would
understand the problem i find that like
you know there's a lot of workflows
there's a lot of optimization kind of
solutions out there but
honestly in my experience it's just as
important to understand the problem
because if you don't understand the
problem even if you know like someone's
told you you know do this to make
something fast or you have to do a
workflow a particular way
that might not click unless you have
actually like lived through the problem
yourself and you see why it's a problem
i think this really applies to like
optimization
you know we're kind of like taught as
programmers that certain things are slow
but it's just so much more powerful in
my experience to see that slowness
yourself you know to profile it to see
that
and then to implement like a solution
and benchmark it and profile it and test
it and see like what a difference that
makes i think that that's
so useful
you know when you're learning um and so
hopefully my kind of intention with with
this kind of optimization october is to
show you that kind of before and after
for both workflows and
um and performance okay so let's dive
into
the current state of things in hazel so
i've actually got two hazel's running
now at the same time this is like the
mesh branch which is like where i've
started doing all this uh mesh workflow
stuff and this is actually project
orange which is hard to see but over
here as you can see this is the orange
um project so
for those of you who want a little bit
of context we basically have like these
orange cubes falling out of the sky and
then you can see when they land
they kind of explode into all these
pieces and in fact we can even when they
spawn we can even actually like shoot
them out of the sky by just like
clicking on them like that right um and
we can like shoot all of these various
pieces as well which is um which is
pretty cool so how does this work and
how does this kind of integrate with a
new mesh workflow so the the idea in the
beginning is basically the same we have
this fractured cube you can see it's
been renamed to mesh source now i can
drag this into the scene
and now basically all i have they're
really the only difference in these
import settings so far
is that i have this static checkbox i
can make it a static mesh or i can make
it a non-static mesh so you can see that
the extension changes as well a static
mesh is currently known as like an hs
mesh so a hazel static mesh whereas this
is just a hazel mesh i didn't really
want to call them dynamic meshes they're
just called regular meshes i guess just
mesh but uh the static meshes are always
known as static meshes so let's create
like a static mesh out of it so i'll
call this i'll just put this into like
demo and we'll call it fraction cube and
it will this will be a static mesh so if
i create this if i go back out here i
made a little demo folder and then here
it is a static mesh so if i drag this
out into the scene you can see that this
is basically the identical like workflow
to what we had before
but the only thing that's changed is
that this particular um
cube as opposed to like oh i've got
another one here
did i create two is that one always
there that's weird anyway there should
be only one of these but um you can see
that uh it's a static mesh right so we
have two different components we have a
static mesh component we can still like
override materials and stuff but
there's only one material slot in this
mesh but it's a static mesh and
usually what happens with static meshes
is that we can add like a mesh collider
to it if we want now i think at one
point it was automatically adding mesh
colliders i'm not sure why it didn't
when we dragged in here maybe that's
something that i need to
change but
we now have this kind of mesh collider
here and what it does is because it's a
static mesh it will create a triangle
mesh collider from it um from physx now
that means that it can't be dynamic but
we can have like you know con concave
kind of geometry and it doesn't need to
be like a convex
uh hull or anything like that for it to
actually be like a dynamic rigid body
and then this you know so so we can
still kind of use this workflow for if
we wanted like a level and we wanted it
to all be static and we can get pretty
uh you know pretty good collision with
that as well but it's obviously just a
static mesh and it's obviously just one
entity now let's compare this to what it
would be like if we wanted this to be
dynamic so the only difference is we
drag in this like mesh source but this
time i will unmark static and i'll put
into that demo folder as well let's hit
create and then uh oh right there were
two last time because by dragging this
in it will also in it also create in
your scene you don't have to go back and
um and you know and drag this in
manually so that's why we had two last
time but uh you can see what it's done
is it's made what looks like the same
thing but if you look in the hierarchy
right this one over here uh it's
actually got that entire like blender
hierarchy replicated over here and these
pieces are all kind of individual pieces
which we can click to select and we can
you know drag them out and all of that
that stuff all kind of works as you
would expect
and
they have also if you look over here
they also are entities with mesh
components not static mesh components
just mesh components
and over here we have a rigid body
applied to them as well and that's cool
because if i hit this button to simulate
physics you can see that it will fall
and it will
it'll shatter right so this is actually
like all entirely dynamic physics versus
this thing over here you can see it's
not going to fall now if i take this
kind of parent entity which is like the
whole object i move it over like here or
something because we added a mesh
collider to this it's a triangle mesh
collider we can also simulate physics on
it and that should work as expected
although now we
yeah we've got this thing here so yeah
work in progress but this kind of new
mesh workflow enables us to actually
make those cubes falling down and
fracturing uh in a much easier way i
mean honestly there are so many features
that i've wanted to add to hazel not
just like refining workflows but for
example like you know we're shooting so
wouldn't it be nice to have little
particle systems like sparks appear when
we hit a surface or decals so that we
can actually like you know have bullet
holes in the walls there's so many
different things that i wanted to add
but i have to stop myself because this
month and honestly not even this month
probably next month as well until i get
through my my massive list of tasks we
are focusing on refining optimization
all that stuff and i think it's kind of
a nice
it's a nice approach and it's a nice
kind of i mean it's honestly just quite
nice to take a step back and do that
because there is massive satisfaction in
refinement and uh you know being able to
take a step back and actually process
all this stuff is both beneficial to the
engine but also it's it's kind of
forcing me to actually think about
the architecture and
like what it is that i'm building and
uh try and improve that as much as
possible because sometimes you can get
lost and just jamming you know feature
after feature and
you kind of begin to create like a worse
product and that's definitely not what i
want to happen with hazel so i'm gonna
keep kind of evolving this game i think
even past optimization october november
you know once we get past all that i'll
still kind of keep this game this
project orange thing as like uh you know
hopefully something that we can kind of
just build up over time i might actually
start posting some of the live streams
here on this channel or edit them down
or something so that you guys can kind
of see the evolution of this game and
just keep up with its development really
let me know in the comment section below
if that's something that you would want
to see otherwise thank you guys for
watching this video please don't forget
to hit the like button patreon.com the
channel best way to help support hazel
this channel all the videos that i make
all of that kind of stuff you'll get
access to this i haven't made project
orange available yet to patrons but
that's something that i intend on doing
uh pretty soon let me know what kind of
videos you would like to see on this
whole optimization kind of topic i you
know my plan is basically as i go
through every item on the list so this
is an example we did like mesh workflows
today as i go through every item on the
list i plan on making a video that kind
of uh you know documents that process
and like what i found and all that stuff
i think it'll get a little bit more
technical when we get to the
optimization stuff because this is
mostly just workflow and it's not that
difficult hopefully for you guys to see
how it works it's probably a little bit
more informative for me to talk about it
from a higher level like i did today
rather than showing you code of you know
hazel specific code and all of that
although if you do want to take a look
at the code of course you can get access
on patreon but now that hazel supports
this new mesh workflow and we can
actually get this game going the next
step is probably going to you know focus
on optimizing the actual performance so
whether that be like the actual renderer
or how prefabs get instantiated the
whole relation like with the scripting
engine and with c sharp that needs to be
uh profiled and optimized a little bit
more but the other thing i really want
to take a look at is shadows because
there are some uh basically low hanging
fruit that we can actually tempt there
are basically just some bugs to do with
that system that should take like 10
minutes to fix honestly so i might take
a look at that thank you guys for
watching have a great rest of your day
and i will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you